I'm domichi director and screenwriter of
Disney and Pixar's turning red in the
film melee is a dorky but confident
Chinese Canadian tween struggling
between being her mother's perfect
daughter and the urge for Independence
increasing pressure triggers a startling
transformation in her she literally
poofs into a giant red panda whenever
she gets emotional or excited the film
was inspired by my own relationship with
my mother and while this is a story
about a girl from a very specific
culture and City I think the story is
incredibly Universal and something we
have all experienced so I'd like to
share one of my favorite scenes in
turning red with you it comes from the
end of the movie and starts during the
Lee family spectacular ritual to save
May's mother who has lost control and
transformed into a raging momzilla and
with the help of her family her besties
and her favorite boy band May and her
mother are able to meet in the astral
plane where they will finally come to
terms with their relationship
it's true
[Music]
this is one of the scenes that came
together almost at the very end of
production this whole idea of May
entering the astral plane and meeting
her mother but her mother is is her age
and and they kind of have this this
moment together and we me and Julia Cho
the other writer for the movie were
thinking like like what is the last step
to May Coming of Age like what what is
that last thing that she needs in order
to like fully kind of mature or grow up
and we thought like that is to see her
mother as not a monster or a goddess a
monolith but a flawed scared girl just
like her
and we use the magic of the astral plane
in order to achieve that like the astral
plane is this spiritual world where the
red panda Spirits reside where the all
of the ancestors of previously family
members rest and it's like a healing
place a calm meditative place where you
kind of like are able to see yourself in
all of your
ugly real raw forms and may sees that
side of her mother that she's never seen
before she finds her mother as a teen
girl crying in the forest and we
purposely dressed her mother to look
almost exactly like may we have her hair
down she's wearing dorky glasses like
may as well and In This Moment the child
kind of becomes the parent in some way
and like May kind of soothes her mother
and gives her the words that she needs
in order to heal from her past trauma
which is you know her mom dealing with
her own Panda transformation her own
very messy adolescence her own
tumultuous relationship with her mother
and may is giving her mom this
opportunity to kind of heal and come to
terms with that
it was important for us to show that
even though May's family like her
aunties and her grandmother are very
over the top in the movie The very blunt
very honest almost too honest kind of
pushy in your face they genuinely care
and love each other and they love and
support me and we needed to show that
her family is behind her decision to
keep the panda but it was also important
for us to show that her aunties choose
to get rid of their pandas that may is
the first in her family to keep her
Panda because me and Julia were thinking
that this is all kind of an allegory for
how newer Generations Embrace change
Embrace messiness and older Generations
through just having to live in a harsher
world having to survive trauma of
immigration of War a famine of whatever
they had to harden themselves they had
to get rid of this wild beast inside of
them in order to serve survive and
assimilate and fit in but may doesn't
have to do that and that it's important
that she's the first in her family to do
so
coming up to the final scene between May
and her mother through the portal we see
May's mother stepping through the portal
releasing her her Panda but then we see
that may decides to stay and to keep her
Panda keep her inner Beast her Wild Side
in her we're really just showing that
this is the beginning of May and Ming
saying goodbye to their old relationship
and in this moment we reveal that it's
very hard for May too that she's scared
to lose her mom she hasn't been able to
admit even to herself in this moment is
that she's scared of change but they
have to let this happen they have to let
May grow up and Forge this new path for
herself you know worked with the effects
department on this portal till they
literally split uh May and her mother in
two different worlds on screen showing
that both of them are now kind of in
different places they still love each
other but it's it's different now it's
it's more from afar so we really
challenged ourselves to come up with
something Maine could say that was I
love you without actually saying that
and then Julia was the one that came up
with that killer line the farther you go
the prouder I'll be and as soon as I
read that I was like that's it like that
is the thesis that is like the drive
behind all parents especially immigrant
parents they try so hard to raise you
right but they know that in order to
truly let you fly they have to let you
go
[Music]
and now I'll let you watch the clip
again without me talking over it
friends
[Music]
you never know
[Applause]
[Music]
mom mom
laughs
Mom are you okay we have to
Mom I'm sorry oh it's it's all my fault
what happened
I I hurt her
who my mom I got so angry and I and I
lost control
I'm just so sick of being perfect I'm
never gonna be good enough for her
anyone
I know what feels that way like all the
time
but
it isn't true
come on
[Music]
oh
I'm sorry
you don't have to apologize
I'm Your Mother
May son ye guide you
and keep you safe
one at a time ladies and quickly
that's it meme is keeping the panda it's
her life now move
[Music]
go ahead
it's okay
[Music]
no no maybe please just come with me
I'm changing mom
I'm finally figuring out who I am
but
I'm scared it'll take me away from you
me too
I see you maybe
you try to make everyone happy but are
so hard on yourself and
if I taught you that
I'm sorry
[Music]
so don't hold back
for anyone
the farther you go
the prouder I'll be
[Music]